what is up everyone what is up welcome
to another episode of rent cafe here at
Anime uproar my name is ana Mack and
today we got a bunch of awesome guests
with us this is episode 39 of Ram cafe
man time flies and in this episode we're
gonna be celebrating than we got over
50,000 subscribers here on the channel
which is nuts
it's completely not over 51,000 now and
we're gonna be having our Q&A just
celebrating hanging out having a great
time here anime out for style welcome
guys mob boys
recon soul maka and Briggs from old
anime is back really happy to see what
the latest video on enemy uproar is man
one piece for kids how I changed it I
haven't watched the epic
gozen could not wait to make this video
like you guys have corrupted him so much
with the one piece that he was enjoying
it yeah he has the whole manga he bought
everything
wow it's out so far and like I have it
all here I want to move the camera but
it's all like in the shells and he's
been reading it and he's got so into it
and he made the video and I love the
video personally like I need to get into
one piece myself but the video you can
watch it even if you don't know but too
much about one piece really good video
hilarious I didn't know like I remember
watching one piece on for kids way back
but didn't really kindly know because it
was so childish I'd really get into it
and now when I watched the video I was
like oh my god no way no way did they
replace a gun with some kind of rubber
hammer and put a cork inside a gun
instead and welcome everyone in the chat
well yeah bricks are you bitten them
pretty good I've been too long since
I've been on a rat cat fan yeah start
coming back here on a weekly basis great
time
Congrats on a 50k man like you guys have
been blowing up and you guys really
really deserve it
thanks buddy I've been working hard and
it's also been really rewarding like
it's not really work if you're loving
what you do and that's what we're to
definitely love doing this talking about
anime hanging out you know making these
videos so yeah and goes and by the way
we'll be in the chat
he's way too drunk to be on camera right
now do you have too much drinking yeah
you know he's celebrating he saw a
writing by visa he is in the comments
yeah
then why don't you celebrate with him
hey man there's no alcohol in business I
promise I'm still recovering right now
I'm so hungover I'm training I have a
beer pong tournament on Saturday for
$3,000 grand prize
did you just see your pot of cold summer
drinking Olympics boy bro
and like I've been training in Briggs
from old anime no song party ladies and
gentlemen he is a beer pong tournament
bro I'm matched with friends ok guys no
no tournaments
I hate me like I've been lately like to
the beer pong fine but I just murder
ball flip cup bouncing games like it's
ridiculously serious $3,000 grand prize
our team name is pokeballs deep I got I
got shirts made and feel like a polka
ball emblem and on the back it says
gonna drink them all man you guys you
guys are heavy
anyways so adam ak what is this gonna be
about today today it's just gonna be
chilling out and having fun party
atmosphere you know answering questions
from people in the chat posing our own
questions to each other to people inside
anything you guys want to talk about we
can talk about welcome Nick and Maki and
remark it's nearly cat gamer original
ink lighten darkness
see you guys there in the chat goes in
in the chat as well
we got a question Adam a uproar why did
you start YouTube
okay so goals then and I started our
YouTube channel goals and start at first
he had a bunch of channels before he was
making a envies and stuff but they get
kept getting picked up by copyright as
you guys know how it works but we've
always loved anime so we would talk
about anime like
watch an enema together or its separate
times but then we would start talking
about it getting all analytical about
and they move like men we saw like get
cook and the anime man make you it isn't
like why don't we make videos since we
talked about it so much anyways and then
we started making videos slowly and yeah
that's how it started and we loved every
moment and it was it's been a great
journey that's nice
how about you guys why are you guys
start making videos especially soul ah I
make videos because I need to teach the
youngest about like quality anime that
may be a bit like before their time that
they may like overlooked or not even
know of so you know I want to try and
get people knowing no phones but my main
goal is to get more people reading
because that's where you get the quality
stuff we didn't manga I'm never gonna
read and you'll never have no quality
I'm sorry gonna read manga well I'm not
really much of a manga person I'm more
into anime the actual show I like to
visually watch instead of reading it
have you ever have you ever watched
something and I know the guy like a
click on your egg and then you need to
find out more and needed to go to the
source material no because I'm a patient
person not like you guys you can't be
patient if it never comes out though ah
okay let's just take this for an example
like High School of the Dead you so you
said that the manga did continue a
little bit right no I never touched a
manga a high school did that I wanna see
now I wanna see that bit of what happens
so why don't you read it I would waste
my money on it because it's just like a
little bit of a little bit you know God
recon swab okay just stop you stop
wasting money to buy manga to support
the industry that you were making
YouTube videos on recon alright fine for
examle
for free on the computer like you pay
for crunchyroll so you can watch anime
you can actually use a section to read
manga on crunchyroll Rika oh really yeah
yeah go to manga on Rika I think I
crunch up like attack on Titan official
manga is on crunchyroll so there is some
magical Oh important question from the
chat guys Roadhog asked that we ever
watch boku no pico and no nor will I
ever watch boku no pico there's this
person right here who has and I regret
it why oh my friends have told me to
check it out I did i watch the entire
thing by the way you can't blame your
friends for that like you can blame your
friends for the first five minutes yeah
until something happens yeah I know once
you realize what's going on the rest of
it is your fault yeah that the rest of
it all on your own you know I just
wanted to see what's gonna happen we
don't want to get it to the spool
Antonio Lopez says congrats thank you
very much Antonio the anime dude asked
what did he miss and what you missed the
enemy dude is that the latest video
before this rank of fail on animal part
is a one piece video what what anime
dude I'm actually enjoying the animes
dudes content specifically because he's
actually analyzing characters from kono
katachi a silent voice and I'm really
loving it yeah I saw and watched
koi no katachi but I've heard great
things
reuse it actually really good the fields
of the film you know it's so good so let
you know you had another account called
hentai bankai yeah I know I just arrived
upon my fight account soul maka is
planning on starting a trail and I
suggested to call it hentai bankai
that was my suggestion
Oh ambu says one piece is my city so
you've seen the new video you've seen
what's up - in fearless opinions and
Amelia's in the chat as well we're
working from we have a question from
Philly's Superman uh do we think that
anime should stray more away from manga
or do we think that um do more original
stories set in the world of the manga
I guess he's asked on the original
versus my let's say original I would
want more original series I don't know I
don't know about that cuz I mean because
basically if we look at like say the
world of boku no hero honor
basically there's that side story
illegals yeah so basically it's like if
illegals only an anime in it and that
was the anime we got for bacchanal hero
and then the cannon story is only in the
manga you know I mean it'd be like that
but if you guys ain't where the legals
then you probably don't know what I'm
talking about but check out we did and
see what you think but yeah yeah yes
yeah yeah like a prequel right no not
well it's not exactly a prequel quality
before the original manga right I don't
know it might do I did I think in a
different theory line though like it
sighs what could happen yes it's just
separate it's just these like vigilante
guys they're out on the street like they
didn't quite make it in it you haven't
they didn't quite make it they've got
their pipes and stuff they want to they
want to be heroes there's one guy who
ain't even got a quirk he's Quercus yeah
and they're all there together and then
a team-up to like catch these like
villains and stuff and then there's even
like cameo appearance of arrays ahead
and stuff so you know it's in that world
we can see that it's in that world
people got quirks even people like as a
head popping up
but it just has nothing to do with the
cannon storyline yeah I mean so I mean
I'm not too sure about that because I
mean sometimes when we get my anime that
like differ form the original and then
give you an alternative ending like most
of them out there for example just off
the top of my head so Lee Claymore you
know those kind of things people tend to
not like them even if they don't have
knowledge of the manga they still feel
like there's something off with them so
I'll probably say no stick to the Canon
material yeah it's always problematic
when you're trying to adapt on the enemy
from a manga and then you stray too far
away I definitely agree with that that
creates problems it's very rare that
it's gonna be better I'm Dion the other
thing though is there can be really good
manga and anime that just don't have a
manga basis at all that are just
originals and I don't have anything
against them like Gurren Lagann alan
gaily and fooly cooly cooly laughs right
there all right really good ones that
are originals re-creators is pretty good
a new one currently airing right so I'm
okay with having more of that however
you can't underestimate you know great
manga and how they're adapt them into
great anime the only problem is when it
takes too long or when they stray too
far away from the source material Kizer
trigger said that we should make a video
about me dancing around to sora hero
days what does it have to create a after
dark channel because that would be a
perfect for an enemy up or after dark
job so you're just gonna completely copy
DT bro yeah it's but better because
recon don't forget that did you grow
came up with the concept after dark
no one oh where did you grow ever used
the words after dark I see I don't know
if you use it you might come after you
what are you gonna do I don't anything
like people say like oh I'm gonna come
after on YouTube we're gonna send hey I
feel like all hey could do with me kinda
better like it not dark though I'm
saying after dark channel yeah
I'm missing in general one like people
are scared to make videos I'm bigger
youtubers or they do something negative
towards a bigger youtuber because like
it's dangerous for your channel by fleek
I've never seen a channel like that
gotten hate from another channel like do
bad because of it if anything it makes
it do them do better
I don't know implicit to listen to me
double for Enderman is a lot of
subscribers but he screwed himself
pretty hard what is craziness
but he's got an own as being a dumbass
in the community it's not because peaky
sent Pete I got like four neverold
scented fans towards them they had a lot
of the same fans and then everyone
realized that double four is like a
dumbass basically I'm like see like
people would be scared to call him
stupid because it like double for anime
might send his fans at me like vibe but
I'd love for him to send us an SEM even
if it's all hated by comments like it's
way better for you
exactly like I could ask her a question
because Josh Duffy I believe his name
was asked me if I think rage you should
join the crew and if like for the one
piece crew and it's between rage ooh
pudding or carrot yes I want to put my
money on pudding or I want pudding to
join the crew just because I think he
she's a better match for Sanji both
being cooks and song he's kinda like a
like a huge gentleman so like he'd be
good for pudding you will they put down
their entire life I had a grade you top
but like that I don't know not super
into her join the crew in sondry sister
anyway go back to normal question types
need answer not only a question no
that's cool appreciate that answer we
had a question from inclement gaming
well what is our favorite anime for me
it's Gurren Lagann four goals in its
combat after story i believe he's still
sticking to that one you guys go ahead I
believe for recon it's highschool DxD
yeah that's right for me um currently is
the movie when money was that nice
that's a good one
nothing beats daughter alone ever but
and Totoro is always gonna be like the
legend anime it's always gonna be there
and for me my favorites one piece and
can eat you the mightiest disciple
everyone go watch can eat you
it's good it's a yep so
konnichi is one of the anime that like
it's like me pushing everyone to watch
gran log on that's old animates version
Rika were you serious about high school
the high school because I'll just
kidding them no no really it's my
favorite animes sio a second Wow
I told you I told you already man I'm
the experiment Aeneas you are sketchy
you know you got a you got a resume I
haven't deny it he embraces it and I you
know you've got to respect someone like
that someone asked I wonder whether if
goes and knows I told everyone he's a
drunk oh yeah what is your stand on
go-go anime and kiss anime and the other
pirate enemy websites I should
definitely get into that one because it
didn't create a huge amount of drama by
the way Grammatik asked do we like drama
my personal stance is that I definitely
believe that people we have crunchyroll
we have the Amazon streaming service we
have Netflix and I think that you should
as much as possible support the services
and buy DVDs blu-rays whenever you can
the problem that I do see that some
people bring up that I think is
legitimate is what about those anime
series that are not available anywhere
like the older ones maybe they're not
out for DVD outside of Japan maybe they
never will released outside of Japan no
streaming service has it so now what are
you gonna do you know you're never gonna
talk about us and they're gonna watch it
because the only way to get it is
there's no legal way for you to get it
or how about people who live in
countries that don't have access that
even the minute they get crunchyroll
they don't get all the rights for all
the anime so they can watch it like so
those people should never become you
know anime fans or anime youtubers
because they can't access anime that
part is difficult for me to swallow
because I believe that everyone should
be able to get into anime so I'm hoping
that well like I said I think you should
support industry whenever you can
I understand that sometimes it's not how
easy or even impossible for some people
but that's specific situations and I
think that as much as possible the
industry should strive to bring as much
anime legally as possible to as many
as possible because that way everyone
wins you can support the industry the
industry gets money and everyone gets
access yep I agree with that there's a
question for weak yeah yeah a question
how am i did so false yeah I'm ready mix
so fast for my top tens well a few of my
top tens were actually as scheduled so
that's why I did them in the UK before I
came here to Germany for holiday but the
others that I do them quick is because
I've been finding time to do them for
like I've been spending a total of like
five hours to do every top ten so like
one hour to do the research and then
four hours to do the editing and putting
everything together so yeah I'm finding
time I've been posting them a lot lately
just you know get them out there and
it's been really really helping a lot
yeah I respect the fact you're hustling
recon because you saw that the you know
people are enjoying the videos your
channel is growing so you're making more
of them to you know keep up the momentum
that's what we did with our channel and
we saw that people are liking our attack
on Titan videos or our cold yes videos
or our let's macademia videos or
whatever we strive to make more of them
but of course striving to make quality
as well and yeah and these do take a
long time to make like a lot of
intensive editing and you do a good job
with the other thing recon so definitely
props on the hustle thank you very much
Anna Mikey Flores will there be a
hangover together in Vegas get drunk a
few amendments and so ends up on the
roof when I turned 21 let's do it like I
said I don't drink so I wouldn't end up
on the roof I drug it sorry Josh Duffy
asked another question my bad
I love Astra answering one few questions
he asked if I hear sorry one second have
to find the question who won the straw
hats do you think will eat the youqi
youqi know me and that's a it's a really
cool theory going around that and I
think it's like basically come for
at this point that the you know me is in
nominees tangerine orchard on the ship
so I personally would want an ami to eat
it because I feel like she's look
basically the weakest on the crew and
the Yukio key you know me has to do with
snow and she's like a whole day or the
uses weather so I just make I think
would make her a lot stronger and it
would suit her the most and I think she
needs a little bit of a power up cuz
she's the weakest and that's my answer
okay I need to get into this stuff so I
understand what you're talking about
so like if someone dies with a double
fruit they're devil fruit gets
transferred to the closest fruit and the
theory is since she the person died on
an island that was like a Snowe Island
and Fire Island so there would be no
like life on it the closest fruit has to
be on like a luffy ship which it has not
nami tangerine orchard and then i'm just
thinking since the week if and she uses
weather abilities it's probably best
fitted for her yeah man honestly like
because i was reviewing those in this
video like i looked it over it was good
after you finished Tennant stuff and i
just like he I can't help but like
getting into the whole concept the world
like as he's talking about it I'm like
man this sounds interesting that God the
Creator old does sounds like an
interesting guy and like the world and
everything so yeah man I will eventually
probably end up getting into one piece
guys I'm calling it good luck watching
all 700 episodes
it might take you months well maybe I'll
just read all the manga Rico yeah all
the manga cost how was it all that
cosmos be fortunate let me be over I
believe I believe goes instead around
$300 but I'm not a hundred percent so
bottom in those big like those big like
volumes but yeah they're all they're all
here that's the real but it seems that
people want you to actually do one piece
content so you'll grow with that so why
don't give it a try
it's all about manga that's I say it's
all about manga really I mean for me for
me anyway languages there's so much more
to manga then there is the anime yeah I
mean like we've animate you stuck with
you know those same generic shows coming
out all the time
the ha rooms yes we know you love them
back on and Sakai
we come on Olli shows and yeah it's yeah
it gets tiring though yeah me when it's
the same stuff and then like an original
anime comes like once every two months
for some you know once every four months
or something it just got so unknown but
then with manga the stories you're
reading you've got more variety like to
choose from now if you want something
really like grim and dark and you know
people get murdered left right and
center you can find it if you want
something psychological and really like
like mind [ __ ] then yeah you can find
that - yeah I mean and yeah we have to
do is be willing to read you know now
luck shocks what is your favorite manga
for me it's anything that makes me like
get really emotional or you know has
some strong feels like bit of virgin
vampire juju Kai was the ev1 koi
one with the girl and she's going out
with a guy and then the guy gets cancer
and he starts being a complete dick to
her to like kind of push her away
because you don't want her suffering
with him kind of thing then she [ __ ]
right then she meets new guy get some
relationship then you find out the truth
and she turns to him to kind of help him
in his last days that kind of things
yeah is really touching I went now
that's another good one as off that's
about a guy who's got like a terminal
disease and basically
engineering like you know genetic
engineering they create like he's
perfect partner to stay with him
throughout his illness and told the day
he does lemming so yo those kind of
things is really you know moving and
touching and nice that's that's my kind
of monkeys anyway you like the
tearjerkers you like oh yeah
yeah I like to be connected to my story
you know I mean and that's what I want I
mean I don't mind like the action and
stuff that's cool like I change one to
food was really good
yeah I mean but I do like having
something more to you know get immersed
in no yeah to me I like I would read as
many manga but probably my favorite
right now will be attack on Titan just
because while I love the anime the manga
is even more fast-paced than the anime
like a lot of extra stuff is left out in
the in the manga it just very fast-paced
and sometimes surprisingly how quickly
goes from one kind of thing to another
so I definitely really enjoyed that and
man I have no issues with the art and
all some people get you know complain
about the art but I have no issues with
it by the way chromic asked any anime
that I dropped definitely Tokyo ghoul
really six goals and as well both also
watch get together we were like great
intro all downhill from the intro
alright back to that other person's
question about you know original enemy
within the world of that a tool like
manga or anime for a prime example of
how it can fail epically just look at
season 2 of Tokyo ghoul cuz season 2 a
Tokyo ghoul was like complete made-up
story and you know it felt like 9
percent people didn't like it so you
know a lot of people say that it was it
was just terrible compared to the manga
SGC says that my hair looks good pushed
back thank you I'm it's getting too long
down to the point where it's just like
closing my eyes so that's what I'm
trying to like push it back now until it
just flows to my shoulders you actually
said in one of your videos which I
really liked
because like you said you don't want to
cut your hair because some anime
characters have very long hair so that
was really badass the anime characters
have long hair it's true are you gonna
leave it long or
you gonna cut it but one point I'm gonna
grow it out and see what happens man
just alright Snorlax what sort of videos
do we like making like top tens or fact
I think it just depends on what type of
top that are fat like I wouldn't want to
make top ten videos just for the sake of
making them well if it's like the top 10
strongest attack on Titan characters or
something interesting like that like top
10 strongest quirks then you know
something like that I feel like it's
interesting about making but what I make
top 10 like anything just to make it I
wouldn't it has to be something that
really like interest me back videos as
well explained as long as it's something
rooted in something that really then I
find interesting like goals ends latest
city on one piece it's like looking at
censorship in anime even though I
haven't gotten into one piece I could
still appreciate a video because it's
like looking at all the ways that they
censored and made one piece more
childish so even though I haven't
necessarily seen it I'm like oh man this
is a great you know great video to look
at and kind of understand look like you
just some of the points are just so
you're oh my god can't believe they did
this like turning real guns into water
guns like oh and I think the reason why
I never got into one piece is if I
watched it know a few episodes back in
the day on for kids and I thought it was
like childish it's probably because of
the four kids that I thought it was
childish in the first place so yeah I'm
a victim of the four kids guys all the
four kids Doug yeah because I was like
top 21 one piece boobs I I saw that
video on YouTube yeah like I didn't
watch the whole video but I definitely
saw it pop up in the in the search
recommendations
top 21 that's what was specific yeah I
don't know for me if I supposed to do
videos or when I do videos
I think I'd more do like like the anime
manga comparisons and like reviews and I
I don't know I don't like top tens
top tens become like an opinionated
thing and then people want to like say
that no you're wrong you know oh why
this included wine this there yeah I
mean so rather than do a top 10 if I
wanted to do like a list I would do a
must-see content pretty much no like you
know like must read manga and then put a
list of them or must see anime and then
I'll put a list of them and you know
well doing like a top 10 because then
that feels to like definitive and then
that's what people take issue with and
stuff so yeah yeah yeah the thing is I
don't really mind I know like like you
said top tens you know get very
combative like with our top 10 worst
quirks in my Erica diamond a lot of
people were pissed but it's like that's
fine generates discussion I don't mind
it well like the thing is a lot of
people are like can we include it in the
worst list and you're like man I would
love to have this quirk in real life
you're an idiot but it's like these are
the top 10 worst critics compared to
other quirks in that world we're not
saying that you wouldn't want to have it
in this world it's just compared to the
other worlds we know of course you know
in a world full of really badass quirks
so that's the thing like you try to
explain it to people sometimes people
don't get it they refuse to listen but
that's part of the whole YouTube thing
like I don't mind if it gets
controversial and stuff as long as you
know it's generating discussion and some
people are just gonna troll for the sake
of trolling but people want to troll
will find the reason to get angry at any
video even at a review or anything like
that do hate comments for your feelings
anime uproar no yeah not it awfully
anything I've been compiling them over
like oh I want to make your life and I
said oh like a reading hate comments
video because like they're so funny oh
yeah it's like it's something to be
expected like I said if you're on
YouTube and you're making content or any
really website or anything no matter
what you put you could try to like
please everyone just be very neutral
you're still gonna have someone just
sort of sacred like you're a [ __ ]
loser bro like that's
people enjoy doing that it's just
because you can't please everyone
they're mainly jealous of you
yeah like some people just want to troll
for this a crook like this is something
we deal with all the time on this court
cuz you guys know that we have anime up
or discord server and we have 18 over
1,800 members now on there and quite
often we'll get someone coming as a
troll just like to spam pictures or just
to be a dick for no reason it's like
they don't know what they were never
provoked to do anything they're just
like oh there's a big discord server
let's go and stir some [ __ ] up that's
just all it is that's how it works in
the end you gotta accept that it comes
with the territory and just move on
adamak the age-old question the question
that has been thought of since the
beginning of time tits or ass ass tits
oppai person right here oh I want wolves
I don't care yeah I'm pretty it's pretty
hard for you I love the female body
because I always watch so yeah for me
it's us it's us boobs then thighs but
Vicky's best that's what has to say
legs is it okay for me boobs hell yeah
as comes second and then legs come last
I'm not really I don't really have a
like fetish so yeah it's like I kind of
do have a leg thing like I see a scene
where the face is a huge thing like top
one and probably my number one thing
with a girl would be a pretty face like
top seven right like man I don't care
what a girl looks like if she has a nice
body but to me it's like face is a big
thing oh I like a girl that I want her
face yeah pretty you have to be stood
with that face in public
what do you think of Lacroix from
Kobayashi I've never seen well she made
sure
affection see I've never seen it because
it just looks like another Moya anime no
it is great trust me good infinite
gaming is asking a lot about seven
deadly sins he asked earlier if we like
the show and now we saw about top 10
things you didn't know about it so no
listen and yeah I like to show some
deadly sins
Briggs likes to show there that suddenly
seven of these senses he's made a lot of
videos on subtly since on his channel so
definitely if you're a big fan check out
his channel link in the description oh
thanks fish huh
oh for sure man I definitely liked the
show my favorite character in that show
I like we talked about this before
Briggs but I loved malleolus and I love
bond the mole so to me it's a tie
between them I don't know I can't pick
um I definitely like bond especially you
feel like you're considering only the
anime but s can or like ask your Noir is
hilarious I love him he's a [ __ ]
badass and he's so strong and I could
not wait for season 2 in January just
because of it you're askin or is hyped
as hell and if you guys have any
questions what the seven deadly sins I
think that might be the one series I
might be no more knowledgeable about
than one piece it's because I've made
like 20 videos on it yeah and also some
that listen is shorter than one piece
right is actually two no but yeah
definitely check out Briggs's channel
for some of the scenes and yeah I'm
excited man I'm definitely as the second
season approaches there's gonna be a lot
more hype so then we can definitely you
know do some more collabs and stuff on
the seven deadly sins because I'm
definitely curious to see everything
that's gonna happen like I've read into
the manga but it's been so long dead
right now I'm like if I watched sex the
second season now it would be like kind
of fresh so I like exactly that's sick
yeah we definitely gonna do a club I'm
horrible and I have no time ever bye I
will hundred percent be down to do
something we had we were talking about
one like Eskin or vs. mellitus type of
thing yeah no definitely it's not a
hurry because there's gonna be more hype
as the season 2 gets closer so it does
not to be right now but definitely some
you should
I have so many amazing ideas that I've
just tried like I've been holding off of
it I'm trying to like put filler content
and type but think about the seven
deadly sins is to keep everyone around I
know it's gonna be so hype one season to
come though yeah for sure
and I don't know recon we got a collab
or we just like to react together no no
I'm serious you're actually bad at it
really done yes let's
let's not get into how many things you
missed in Knox's reaction that were so
obvious no I didn't know I actually did
not miss any of things you know what he
was saying because when you react here
on the spot and I understand no I was
giving honestly things and a thing that
he was saying I was fixing it for him
like he would be saying one thing your
did you just say this thing and you'd be
saying like sarcastically or someone
yeah so I think recons definitely better
reactor then adamak obviously but I
because you were reacting to our
sarcastic anime trailer or a stochastic
Fox I feel like you have a hard time
kind of like interpreting some amounts
of sarcasm sometimes because I don't
like people making fun of the show while
I defend it you know when he was he was
making fun of people who were making fun
of the show for overdoing it and you
think he is making fun of the show
that's the problem
you didn't yeah but I would never want
to be a reactor youtuber guys believe me
[Laughter]
recon who's better reacting me or adamak
guy reacted with you for like a thousand
of berserk
that's better I was pretty bad well the
thing is when one of the atom activities
when he did the äôt see got so much Hey
look like that before
what the [ __ ] are you doing it's it's
when Aaron was actually about
transformed it started to the be writers
ass was funny right he looks like
I saw the bit
I saw where people were complaining I
went back to the bed I was like okay
what's wrong with it nothing is wrong
with them but people were mad the fact
that he was missing the point on Aaron
no yeah but that's the problem people
are mad that people other people don't
react exactly as they would which is why
that community is ridiculous it's like
you watch reactions to see people react
exactly as you would and if they don't
you get mad which is so by the way also
we never did like actual recorded
reactions what we did is we live
streamed and like chatting we would be
chatting with people as we're watching
the show and then it would get people
saying you idiot you're not even
watching the show you're just looking at
your phone because we're looking at that
right this isn't a reaction channel
we're just like watching and kind of
chatting with our leaves as we're
watching that's what we were doing it's
not a react but Internet the final total
respect for you when you do a live
stream I have total respect mmm good oh
okay keeper wants to get noticed by
senpai I believe that I'm your son pie
so I will notice you he asks what's your
favorite series and movie if we're
looking at me my favorite series would
be Gurren Lagann my favorite movie my
neighbor totoro but i love also castle
on the sky a bunch of Ghibli films 100%
a huge fan of those and there's other
anime movies that are great like paprika
and Tokyo Godfather's and so many non
Ghibli films Akira ghost in the shell'
but like the ones that most speak to me
are the Ghibli films that are just like
the feels man it's like a spiritual
experience watching that's why i rewatch
like my neighbor totoro castle it's not
like twice a year under % it's like a
meditative thing for me I love it um
original link asked me how I get the
cherry blossoms to blow in front of my
videos um
you thought trade secret I actually to
relearn how to do it because I have like
it preset like so like whenever I open
up a new file and funny Vegas I it's
reopening that for my basic one but I
lost all my a lot of my stuff when I
broke my computer so briefly just
download cherry blossoms like animation
from YouTube and then if you put it in
like a Sony Vegas track or at Adobe
Studios track and you just kind of like
there's a setting to set it to an
overlay or a screen and it gets rid of
all the block in the background so you
only see the the cherry blossoms and put
that as your first uh as your first
track like your first hopefully what the
hell man I thought you were you were
like you had like a cherry blossom
branch you just say exactly what I do I
throw them in myself I'm recording
myself throwing them asks me what do you
specialize it what does that mean like
is it what anime do I like yeah what
anime do you specialize in autumn ha
she's my favorite I've got a question of
my own but I've got something I need to
address first which the animating said
and I have to say to the anime dude coin
oak Itachi is better than your name I
agree I agree deep is the deeper story
it's not like superficial idealistic you
know oh look at this everything turns
out pretty it's magical it's actual deep
story with real character types you know
people that you can actually meet in
life yeah I you on the concept that
things being idealistic or turning out
happy is a bad thing I think some of the
best movies do that and I think that's
the in anime because I'm so sick of
negativity and cynicism that we see in
media today I don't want to live my life
as a cynic as a negative person's like
my life sucks man like I want to be
idealistic
I love Romanticism as an art movement I
love the idealism of someone like
kameena and like the idea of doing the
impossible so I personally love those I
think they're very more
Vasia yeah but I'm talking about
realistic but yeah the thing I
understand but that doesn't make it
better
realism is one thing but realism is not
necessarily better than idealism yeah
yeah yeah well then what yeah that comes
down to preference and yeah you want I
know no one to die you know you know
like like seven deadly sins basically no
people don't die they will survive yeah
yeah yeah people want stuff like you
suck
you know people dying you know having to
overcome real problems people can be
inspired by seeing others overcome real
problems and see that and go okay
if he can go over that maybe I can apply
that in my own life and go over it in
this kind of way yeah I mean so it works
both ways really but it's just it's down
to what you prefer but yeah I definitely
agree with what you just said but it
stood out like just kinda want to spend
the 7 of these things a little bit
because it's not for everyone if you
like to see people die berserk is
amazing it's one of my favorite anime
actually preferred for the manga to be
honest but um 4/7 at least since most
people go only off of what they've seen
in season one and them not dying has a
lot more meaning like later on
officially Mele Otis and as an Elizabeth
and stuff like that it's it's actually
crazy how much I'm gonna twist like how
different the story becomes greater on
in the manga compared to season one
because they were alive in it that
they're alive but it's so much deeper
than meaning like there's actually a
reason for people surviving like a
Mellie Otis being alive and stuff like
that and it's pretty crazy or shadowing
even in the first season
err stuff there's foreshadowing that
when I rewatched it I was like oh I see
what's something with like Elizabeth's
power because when I first saw the first
season of the NL's are what the fog just
seems like an [ __ ] but then if you
actually
rewatch the first season you see a bunch
of times where it's hint
that Elizabeth has this power it's true
but no yeah I know what you mean so
phantoms wheel asked our am I gonna make
a manga or manga anytime soon and no I
am a writer I have written published
fiction before I'm trying to get a book
there's inaudible however I'm terrible a
visual art so I can't draw so I'm going
to make a Mong anytime soon
unless a I find an artist that wants to
work with me and then together I would
work with them but that would probably
be down the line but don't I would
definitely go if I was gonna make
something I'll definitely manga furs and
try to get right into anime because
anime is a huge undertaking for sure so
I'm not ruling it out I just don't have
any plans in the near future but it is a
cool idea yeah did you guys end up
having that like we where we all did our
pitch or Adam a pitcher
no what happened oh I missed it oh it
didn't happen is you know good good that
you reminded me on our discord guys link
in the description we are having out of
writing contest and it's gonna be like
anyone can participate and you have a
one-page kind of space to create a
concept for a new anime so you know you
create the the concept for the anime
what what would the anime be about would
be the main character is like a basic
kind of outline and we're gonna have a
competition and the five most
interesting ones we're gonna actually
read them live on a special episode of
rent cafe and we're gonna pick a winner
on RAM Cafe so we're gonna like the
people on rank if they're gonna be the
judges and that kind of stuff so yeah
that's gonna be like a really
interesting thing that I'm looking
forward to and if you want to
participate this Court is in the
description
silver elf our boy is organizing the
contest working hard on that so thank
you to em may I propose sorry I do I go
ahead recon I answer a question
Sharma asks me what do you think is
better Sundari are young during I would
say Sunbury summaries are better than
younger is yeah I'm I think I'm more of
a cinder a guy in liking cinder A's but
Y Andres
often make the show better than sind
race Andreas can be annoying if done
wrong they're funny I mean like most of
the lines recite because it's it's sweet
it's cute
because she sometimes likes the main
characters but she doesn't show it until
the very end so that's what I like about
something it has to be done right yeah
it's been overdone and that's why people
get sick of it because we just see
bloody time yep understand but we don't
see yonder is very often so exactly
exactly
that's what I was trying to say sorry go
ahead
yeah key da from school Bravo is
definitely not a good tune there so I
definitely understand how to nurse can
be letting overdone cat gamer by the way
says that everyone tells him he's too
young to write good stories
the thing that writing is you have to
write in order to get better at writing
so even if you're young and you don't
have experience yet you have to write
right now in order for your writing to
improve so right away if you want to be
here right
if you want to be a writer at any point
in your life Briggs go ahead I just
wanted to say Cinderella and one and y
Andre like that's I guess kind of their
character trait or the way they act but
I like characters that go beyond like I
like the cinerea aspect I really like
cinder ace to be honest a little bit of
a weakness for them but um like I feel
like if that's all they are that that's
their only character type like that's
all they are is a cinder a then they're
pretty basic and boring over time or if
they're not like a fleshed out character
on their own for example astana seem
like a badass in the beginning and then
like see what kind of went cinder a
witch was cute I liked it
but then she didn't do anything beyond
that I think that was their only purpose
was being that cinder a type for a bit
and I like I like the trait or like I
like Yonder ease as well but that's all
you are is the crazy [ __ ] and you're
not like interesting or well fleshed out
beyond that and your briefs are kind of
like I'm not into that type of like I
think it's the weak character because
one dimension on is this is only one
dimension and that if there are only
like that's the only thing they do is be
a cinder a then it's born yeah yeah and
the thing is I fear that I I feel like I
like sue there isn't
life men I think that's a problem for me
because for me if our girls like screw
you buddy who cares about you I'm like
oh man no I like her more you like the
challenge nice to me I'm like oh she's
nice to me so I know I know she likes me
but if what girls like screw you like Oh
challenge challenge so yeah not good not
a good habit to like some that is but I
feel like I have a weakness for them in
real life but yonder is like a band of
Oh in overlord I like I don't like
yandere who are full on its name but
yandere who are like a little bit crazy
and love but you know you can still they
could still function as human beings I
say don't like you know cos I'm what
about you know no she's insane that's
that's different because Alberto chieng
insane in it but she's like crazy
defensive over her guy yeah I mean and
yeah but it's nice though and then she's
got the fun side as well like where
she'll be like in his bed with a body
pillow yeah I mean so it's not just
constantly you know dissing Saint chick
constantly like stalking him anyone who
gets near him she's pulling out a knife
yeah yeah like she'll like obey the will
be like oh how dare you you know speak
to him this way should I kill him my
lord and he'll be like no relax it's
like okay she won't just go on like
murder someone behind his back like yeah
yeah and she knows that tights like in
public in you know you see I act
impolite and stuff and you know things
like that you you wouldn't get that from
you know yeah I didn't functional you
have to be able to function as a normal
person by the way a peerless opinion
says overlord season two also keeps us
waiting yes definitely waiting for O
Lord not read the manga knocks tuck was
hating on overlord last week but I
personally enjoy overlord quite a bit I
wasn't crazy about her I liked it in the
beginning it just like you I feel like
you're into like sometimes overpowered
characters there's like badasses and
stuff like that well I like to see like
someone get stronger and better over
time and the hell would you like more
than just no crying all over their face
Renton Thurston second
no I think I think get mixed up with the
word badass and overpowered it's true
like because Kirito is overpowered oh oh
no I'm just giving an example right he's
overpowered but he's not a badass
no he doesn't even matter things are
like wait hear me out first
there's title yeah from Kenshin
we won't intention Saito the guy who he
fights
I very much to bring out his potosi side
yeah that guy was a badass yeah he
wasn't overpowered he was a badass look
at his character look at the way you can
yeah I mean I don't think we might ask
this means like killing people are not
giving a [ __ ] no no no I think it's
never Savage no the persona you give off
you're a badass but I feel like yeah
when you say like big old about ass I
think is about us yeah you don't have to
do something insane to be a badass let's
take this for example
so how do you think I thought about this
question super quick you think beagle
with about us from what from cowboy yes
watching Cowboy Bebop no I've seen him
I've seen him and I say yeah oh wait no
it's episode 1 - no he's a badass with
his like suave cool demeanor his
one-liner is badass fighting style you
see it for monies capture done was a
Valentine go save Anton yeah you see it
from them
really yeah I mean and you know you can
see that and that's what I mean when you
look at Kirito you do not feel that we
do not feel that no logo powered he's
he's overpowered and that's cool yeah
he is you just don't know him you don't
know just me
I know Kirito I know soul I agree and
disagree for example I made a mistake
when I described the character from what
they called Overlord you're right he
overpowered not about us though I am
here don't have some small not a badass
in him while he is overpowered kubrick's
he does hi I'm defending him I forgive a
little bit of a badass I know you're
still saying kiri toes not really a
badass live reactions right here classic
example
Briggs is trying to defend Kirito from
soul and recon
[ __ ] you Briggs no thank you listen boy
you don't understand where he's not a
badass and that that is the point where
as I said ok I'm saying the guy from
over Overlord isn't a bad overplay he's
not overpowered but he also has elements
of being a badass I can't say he's a
huge badass because I'm I've just
finished talking with spike Spiegel who
is 10 times better and on another level
but I will admit Kirito is a little bit
of about us so so when when K equals
angry when he's fighting out of anger he
looks like about us that's what you
saying yeah no it's more when he's calm
he's like he's he's a calm cool
character when he's calm and cool I
heard about him so he's a [ __ ] solo
player he doesn't need anyone to help
him that's what makes him badass no no
no that just makes him overpowered no
doors are knocks and soul and Briggs and
me like everyone is against you for some
reason I'm defending Kirito a little bit
I wouldn't say he said he wasn't he said
but I all know it's funny
he conquered you can handle any
negativity that's
because your savior because all it is is
freaking negativity once anyway shut up
to Luna I'm by the way in the chat Slav
asks who here likes karma from
assassination classroom at Karma is
definitely a badass he's actually under
alicante super overpowered at all Karma
I feel like he has a lot of faults
himself and can't do everything like the
main character it's a little bit better
of an assassin than him but I think
karma is a badass by the way he acts
yeah but to me Nagi summer boy Nagi says
a badass to man who's the one that just
straight-up kissed a chick in the middle
of a fight scene it wasn't a karma
Brahma was my boy dog ISA and I was
watching that and I was like and I was
as those hobbies like is he gonna kiss
her is he gonna kiss you yes yes it
happened bro it happened I didn't miss a
question from sloth earlier he says a
lot of harem protagonists are pansies do
you agree also ah data from 27 your
thoughts on his character well Herman
protects our past seas I would say one
of the most ones is I think aku from my
Sukhoi he's a little bit of fancy
Trinity auditor from 2007 he's not fancy
at all I think he's a dope character
he's awesome what what about you guys
what do you think they definitely have
some undesirable traits it's cuz they
try to make people image blind or like
as the people like anyone could relate
to them even if but I'm definitely a lot
of pansies in MCS is most of the time
you question why do these girls even
like him yeah that is true yes there
should be a good reason and why these
girls are into the guy even if it's
cliche or stupid of having reason and
makes a difference
but what is your most pansy harem
protagonist mine would be rocky from
nice if Anissa Cory brought them haven't
watched enough him to even remember
anything we're not like you
No thank you we kept them with a camera
any anyone's names you guys are not true
Heron Kings like me what's the guy's
name in like we never come to be okay
say it again Briggs I can't remember
something stuck i what's the series I
thought the show with me at something
fat guy but whatever even monster
boosted me the guys a little bit of
appended what from the guy he kind of
lays out in the first episode yeah I
have a way better example but I remember
the animes name okay what can I talk I
think Animax thinking what do you think
adamak what is the question
MC protagonist where he's a fancy in the
hair me yeah in herre like useless oh
the guy from girls Bravo the main guy
yes oh yeah yeah yeah really allergic to
girls like literally so I saw some sicko
I was frustrating God and then the other
guy who quia I'm up is like the opposite
of him he's like a crazy deranged
pervert so that show is just a mess but
it's kind of like yeah you can Ari's his
name goes endows he goes a nose so were
you talking about sick I mean brings
read talking about sickening that one
yeah yeah yeah we're all the girls
protect one guy yeah like I understand I
think he got good later on it something
and I had it for this kind of a reason
no that didn't okay like even in the
beginning like he was completely useless
and all these girls wanted him to be
their master type of thing for the game
when there was probably so many better
options and preferred no reason they
wanted them technologic technologic here
because he got more secure it made him
able to get more separate basically yes
that's how it works
no doubt that was the legitimate reason
given oh because I have like for sacker
a you're able to get more secretaries
that what
it kind of got to make sense well if you
have more Pokemon it's easier to catch
more Pokemon but you only have one it's
kind of little bit harder if he's weak
you know stupid bro that is nothing with
voluntary joke okay
grandma asks what is the best villain
planet to me it's a villain of this
ideology like a motivation that you can
relate to so even if you don't agree
with his actions you can see where he's
coming from that's the best villain for
me a villain Oh cuz lucky from collab
yeah absolutely
he's a great guy luna asks me what does
he pay for genre alongside herman itchy
romance is alongside more walking like
oi - so the few things yes I am watching
it it's beautiful it actually might be
the only anime on like 10 times better
than Cousineau Hong Kong
I gotta understand how like no-one's
talking about koi - who so and like it's
not even like caught on like certain
websites and stuff and then there's all
this other atoms I tried watching I
dropped it in the first episode someone
mentioned in the chat a few bill
mentioned cooking guru E and yeah I'm
good I don't know like I want to hate
that anime but I just keep watching it I
don't know I'm enjoying it but it's not
as good as people make it out to me I
don't like I don't think I don't think
it's good it's just for some reason I
keep watch again it's like a guilty
pleasure
currently what the [ __ ] is happening I
want to see more you know a show about
two animated mouths who made it he's on
work break bro is here as well welcome
grill bro
I like the right face isn't [ __ ] you
better worry that's what makes me watch
him I don't get that I don't care for
that at all but it's just intriguing
it's like why where are they going with
this what is happening what what kind of
pisses me off is I feel like she wins
disgust she's super smart or like it's
not like she goes in with us like well I
like what no game no life they'll have a
super like in that strategy I know
that's like you're not a huge fan of it
on a Mac what I like about it like at
the end you find out like they plan
stuff in advance they didn't just go in
blind wanting the
amble and then like just they wind cut
they're super smart they're super smart
but they're smart enough to plan in
advance come up with a strategy like get
people to work with them and it's like a
set up type of thing an islet I I like
it could I could under I understand how
they did it and we were able to like
outsmart them even though they're
obviously gonna win
while in [ __ ] like kakigori or whatever
it's called she just wins cuz she's
super smart and goes in blind you know
like she doesn't mean all the time
though so that's fair she kind of fair
use this Machiavelli invert to which is
the concept that if you wanna um you
know have fortune on your side you have
to take initiative you have to like
excuse me you have to like go for the
throw that you can't be like
half-hearted make the people who are
pulled are the people who get more
fortune kind of thing so I do respect
that aspect for bogey in the light it's
like yeah that you they're real they're
strategies at the end but their strategy
strategies are so out there that you
couldn't possibly it's almost like deus
ex machina it's like what what are you
talking on one could have predicted what
you predict it like it's insane yeah
it's not realistic it's not realistic at
all but like it make it's kind of like
for example I don't get too much
appreciation and I don't feel super like
good about when she wins I'm happy one
day I also like their characters better
but like I'm happy when they win come
like Wow like even though I couldn't
think about it and it was ridiculously
like unrealistic it was still something
like wow like it like it shocked me and
like it was cool hockey think about it
and they went in with a strategy versus
like I don't appreciate when she wins as
much or even when she loses even though
it's realistic that she could lose and
win because she's going in lined that's
the thing with cocky blue do we I don't
necessarily feel connected to any of the
characters either that's like you said
it's just like what is gonna happen next
like where are they going with this it's
crazy yo uh adamak I actually have to
dip thank you so much for having me I
will definitely be back more in the
future I'm the computer so I'm
definitely gonna be back
Congrats on 50k bro you guys definitely
deserve it but I got a dip
thanks man bricks later recon what is
Forex
I love you and just
I'll see you all next time shrim popular
good man phantoms will ask me about akka
mega kill but I actually didn't watch it
because I heard everyone says that it
ending is so bad that I was like I'm not
gonna bother watching this so that's why
the dog was popular anime that I did not
watch I actually liked the end and I
thought the ending was good the ending
was better in the anime than it was in
the manga oh wow really you're saying
that you yeah yeah yeah I am I brought
him yeah you need to see how bad the
ending was in the manga you also like a
saying that animate changes were
actually better that is probably a first
in history definitely yeah Luna asks me
what does it take to become a harem King
/ Queen yeah what does I'm curious
well you came to the right place to
become a true harem King like I am you
must watch a lot and I mean a lot of the
harem edgy like like a lot of them you
have to become a true harem King so yeah
being a true hair King mean that in real
life
anime become a true having King and
anime so yeah I wanted to know and you
need to know the funny thing bill what
your girls in real life will love them I
don't have a ham in real life but I do
you're not the true harem King I am an
anime you have to get the right wife
used to come home you have to analyze
the waifu's in the shows and then put
them and build your harem that's what
you need to do I have a kind of a harem
I have a woman and two boys and they all
love me I swear know what the woman not
related to you to love you well for Luna
it might be hard because she's a girl
and she needs boys to be in her hair so
I don't know much boys who are good
Pindos I know you have kind of a
swimming team oh boy yeah Kirito could
be in your harem Luna would you would
you love care to be in your harem I
think he should I would be happy if he's
in your harem by the way guys by the way
for next week's topic on right okay I'm
thinking about discussing what it would
be your quirk if you were in the world
of my hero academia what kind of quirk
would you like to have whether existing
or one that you made up so let me know
in the chat if that's something you're
interested in discussing next week
because I thought that would be an
interesting discussion to kind of just
see what kind of quirks we like that we
know exist and what kind of perks we
would made up make up if we could yet
there's no doubts have we seen them D
Grayman and I'll say yes I read the
manga I'm up-to-date with that and I've
also seen both seasons of the enemy also
anime is life asked what is my favorite
anime opening and that's the question
there's a lot of really good ones
um Cowboy Bebop opening is amazing
Gurren Lagann opening Death Note first
opening I'm not a fan of the second the
music I know a lot of people like it
though um darker than black has a really
good opening creators has a great
opening re-creators a really good song
for sure what about cold is cold Geass
has a lot of great openings absolutely
colors is probably my favorite but yeah
yes so there's no elements so many guys
there's so many goes to the shell stand
alone complex has a beautiful opening
like just amazing yeah I like no
experiment in Mullane great teacher
onizuka has a really cool opening
drivers hi Omega is asking about
classroom via leaf I personally have not
watched it that's one of the ones that I
haven't watched this season watch it
please the main character Iona
coochie-coo is a God he's a God in the
series oh my god I
the idea like it it just uh yeah it's
too generic okay now so you need to eat
it just keep my watch the first episode
you watch the first episode only keep
watching it
why subject myself to that I watch the
first episode I saw where it was going
and I was like no not to me you're just
watching the first episode you know the
three wrote the three episode test give
it three episodes okay do that because
at the end of day things have got so
generic these days that you don't need
to you can see it I know that happens
you carry on watching it and you'll
prove in line but you're missing the
point
you're missing the point of what's gonna
it's currently happening in the series
trust me
episodes I like I watched two episodes
of knights and magic and I was like no
this is the most generic [ __ ] yeah you
guys I'm like I bet you felt like that
from the first episode donut yes but I
want it I wanted to see something to
spice it up just me and Mack it does
spice up a lot I mean I mean a lot of
spices up I don't trust you because it's
like just ask the people ask the people
in your tribe ask the people in the chat
they are yeah I see someone in the chat
saying so Marc isn't oneness that's why
I see mature
[ __ ] you region puppets don't you I
don't demotivation grammatic yes I know
all I need to watch Jojo everyone to
knock stock who won't let go of the Jojo
thing so I will eventually watch it
devil the rebel donated two pounds -
Cindy Congrats of 51 case subs what
about Anna macking goals and made
cosplay now I told you at 1 million
devil the rebel so I don't know about
girls and maybe he wants to do it but
for me it's 1 million bro no more no
less
paradox Palin asks me what do you think
about essays reasoning behind being
cautious
the girls around them being due to
trauma caused by uh from rider and being
scared eternally of being betrayed again
that's a very good question
notice I really wouldn't know the answer
to that go go go to paradox Pat paladin
he just said it like it like just a few
seconds ago I wouldn't really know what
the answer to that soul maka is right in
the chair that's what I've seen no
people don't understand they don't get
it yeah I think that's legitimate I
guess I mean it's been like mentally
scarred or traumatized by something is
natural to then shy away from something
for fear of that pain again I mean
that's that's just a normal human
reaction it's like if you burn your hand
in the fire you're not gonna want to
stick your hand in a fire again I yeah I
mean so yeah it makes sense he said he
says crap like like highschool DxD you
shouldn't be watching that boy you
shouldn't one of the greatest heritage
series I've ever watched yeah I could
not get into the plot Oh highschool DxD
are all like with a hole well you can
always keep on arguing it all the stuff
but I know for sure that never watch the
same anime like we just like i watch so
they think oh high school high school
dxd and everyone knows why you're
watching paid for and like the plot just
feels like stupid like you just watch a
hentai with a plot that's why like watch
a hentai why watch it high school
evening I don't get it yeah you don't
get more pleasure and it's not it look I
I don't watch hentai well I didn't watch
boku no pieces yeah no no wait wait wait
you were you watch that skirt and all
knuckle thing in it maybe and as a
hentai right
maybe guys go guys recon watches every
ant you look it's a seasonal enemy so I
watch almost all of them just what
happens look okay okay the point is
hentai is like highschool DxD except
they go all the way and they take out
the cringy plot so there you go yeah
harems do have a great story plot though
I mean everybody wants the MC to choose
the best girl and in some series he does
that but in more in those cases that
wouldn't happen the way you wanted like
the main girl that you want them MC to
choose might not even be chosen in the
series so my point is I know that
there's what's up Zeke I know that
there's harems that are good like like
Clannad or like Kanaan or Angel Beats
whatever but I'm saying over to talk ed
Chi harems are like why not just watch
harem hentai if you want to watch over
the top mg it's like they're showing you
so much actually anubias stop I'm not
going all the way and including some
filler plot like what's the point of
that like I'm not saying all harems are
bad but you're talking about over to
talk edgy type here laws is telling me
to wave the white flag and surrender we
got Joe don't talk too much
Joe Joe harem so great story applauds
you know I think you know to be honest I
think I should surrender because it's
two against one saw I have no one to
back me up I know it's not two against
one
it's the whole chat against one no bring
your bring your friends or you can find
someone who's gonna defend you will have
them on on the early one will give you a
year you should find someone with any
good you know and your first line to
them has to be sao is the greatest anime
No sao is the second greatest enemy
after high school yeah oh yeah and they
have to agree with you I'm looking
forward to more and cafes like it's just
that well I can't people just respect
other people's opinions that's what I
want that's what I want you to guys do
you defend their opinion it does a thing
to defend it with logic and facts to be
able to defend it that's the thing yeah
and especially yes especially when like
cuz especially when it's something there
isn't Wow when it's something that's not
objective but purely like subjective
like for instance the argument of
idealism with like realism like which
one is better or you know it comes down
to personal preference and yeah I mean
but we we've got cases where realism
upsets people so like say a comedy kill
ya
loads of deaths happened in a war make
sense it's realistic but loads of people
got upset with it because they wanted
something idealistic they wanted the
positive everyone winning you know hero
saves the day and lives yeah I mean but
then you've got the other side you got
too much idealistic fairy tale he was
never [ __ ] wait what the [ __ ] like no
no so there you go yeah we've got
extremes for both cases yeah we and then
it just comes down to personal
preference whether you accept it yeah I
mean some people might accept fairytale
and you say well you know it's like how
it is a joke it's cool don't worry about
it yeah I mean and then others accept to
becoming a killer like a look they'll
fight in a war people die that's what
happens yeah I mean you know it's just
down to personal preference
but no I prefer idealism okay yeah yeah
but I think there's
so you can have a really well executed
idealist show a realist show and you
have pulled poorly executed ones as well
you can have a realist show that's like
Oh everyone dies but yet it's also like
no you don't care about the characters
so when they do die you're like who
cares kind of thing right yeah well I
think I think what it's about is having
that balance
take for instance goin loggin yeah we've
gone loggin we've got the idealistic
idea of nothing is impossible in it so
long you believe in yourself you have
that will you can go and reach it in it
and that is idealistic okay but we've
got the realism of right you know
oh boy come in a dying we've also got
the realism of Nia's life being forced
like being joined with the Annie spirals
and then for when they got rid of them
they're near then goes okay whoa is then
left kind of like giving up that kind of
battle and passing over the mantle yeah
I mean so it's balance it's not just
pure idealism yeah I mean it's balance
it has that realism it has that other
edge to it to like bring it down and not
just be a show of just like pure crazy
hope and everything's gonna work out and
don't you worry your little head about
it yeah I mean so yeah it's like we're
like no one dies you can't go die it's
like oh no they're saying ya know well
we see coming to die and comes back
right next episode you know that what
yeah yeah no I agree with you by the way
Joe Joe says he has to go eat but he
says congrats on 50k Thank You Jojo
you're good dude I think it's time to
wrap this up guys they were almost an
hour and a half in but I want to thank
you all again so much for 50,000
subscribers for being a part of the
community here at Ranka fan watching all
the other videos drop a like if you
liked grant afraid to let us know and of
course in the comments let us know some
future themes and topics you want to
discuss also don't forget that we're
having a bunch of party events this
Saturday we're gonna have a twitch party
playing some twitch party games
celebrating 50k and this Sunday we're
gonna have an all-day discord party on
our discord server hanging on voice Chad
watching anime together getting drunk
but pretending that we're not getting
drunk that kind of stuff right recons
gonna get sloshed as we say it's gonna
get hammered I'm not gonna give up I'm
gonna get us all hammered and then he's
gonna explain to us why yes say oh and
harems are the best and we're gonna be
like damn it it makes so it makes too
much sense so yeah alright thanks
everyone on all your congratulation
DeNooyer so far it really means a lot is
easy to think of it number 39 ranked off
a number one we were at just hit two
thousand subscribers so that gives you
perspective on how you know how much the
channel has grown and all that stuff and
the community it's been amazing soul
thank you for joining us soul is gonna
be starting his own channel sometime in
the future
hentai bankai or whatever he decides to
name it discord isn't that right soul oh
yeah definitely you can turn this code
all the time on a night I'll be in the
voice chat general channel so I'm always
there you know fresh in our ideas
debates with people we talk about all
sorts daily life anime manga gaming you
know consoles vs. PC all kinds of stuff
so I mean if you want to catch me you
can catch me there anytime and to Slav t
375s question I'd have to say
Kabuto because Obito was a liar okay
over over to you Ethan Rika
anyways what up is your boy recon I do
reactions for seasonal anime and I also
do some quality top tens which you guys
might find interesting
and yeah harem animes are the best
highschool DxD comes first SEO comes
second and yeah subscribe to my channel
because I'm actually almost two at 20k
so yeah five hundred seven away and to
not questioning congrats on the hustling
link in the description to recount
Channel and for not Sue's question he
asked is it a sin if you watch
highschool DxD and your Christian no it
is not a sin so yeah he is fantasy
I mean some people think Harry Paul
water watching Harry Potter is a sin
because it's witchcraft but to me is
like religious but I don't necessarily
think that everything that is fantasy in
a different world from ours needs to
apply to our own religious world right
well yeah guys thank you so much again
for all the support goes in over there
in the chad you drunk today good job if
you guys want to check out the latest
video you can see it on our channel and
yeah until next time until next week
see uh space cowboys be sure to do it in
to the old a discord party we'll be
hanging out all weekend whoo